let's jump to this next story from TMZ I
love this TMZ great reporting here
ex-trump officials refute DOD claim
three had flown here before yo TMZ hits
the nail on the head they're like look
we have several guys who would know
former Director of National Intelligence
former Secretary of Defense and former
Secretary of State all saying no
balloons Flew Over the U.S during the
Trump Administration when this when this
okay so this weekend I'm looking at my
phone and I see a story breaking three
balloons fly over the U.S during Trump
Administration I thought to myself well
you know if we're wrong we'll own up to
it we'll go on the show and say we stand
corrected because we said under Trump
this never would have happened and if it
did he'd have shot him down and now here
it is wait a minute what's this an
anonymous official said
in some report so so we have no evidence
nobody saw it happen nobody reported it
no no Pilots no Aviation experts no
aviation industry individuals like not a
single photographer no one ever saw
anything like this happen no one's
reported and three three officials have
refuted it huh I know if I waited 10
minutes the story would be debunked and
now here we are fake news well it's so
they double speak in the statement they
say three undetected balloons one across
the United States well if they're
undetected dumbass how do you know they
came across the United States meaning
you if this is true you did detect them
but you didn't tell the
commander-in-chief about it well what's
that called treason well the official
anonymous quote is Chinese balloons
briefly transited the continental United
States at least three times during the
prior Administration
here's my favorite part so these three
officials come out and they say it's not
true
so you know the bite Administration just
came out and said this morning
they said we only just discovered it
happened now and we will brief former
Trump officials on this
get up out of here you guys didn't
detect them but we have detected them
that's right we'll let you know because
because they have the they have the the
Osiris device which allows them to look
at this giant crystal and Rewind time
and look at the skies previously through
you know so they can like look in the
past in the future you know I'm having
these visions of being in the Oval
Office running this because this is so
like more and more it's actually really
happening to me I'm like okay this is
what it looks like these are the
documents that you get in the morning I
mean I could have some like I'm ready
like this I cannot sit by as old man 85
gets elected another yeah you know you
know little kids are better Liars than
this my kids are better yeah my kids lab
would stick up longer than that yeah but
look we might get it but how many people
like the krasensteins for instance are
are ignoring the fact that three former
officials said no it didn't happen they
don't care they're they are satisfied
with one Anonymous official saying it
happened boom there it is it happened
and I'm like okay live three named
officials and the simple fact that
there's no evidence to suggest this
didn't happen but I gotta tell you Ian I
think they're in the Oval Office and
Biden sit there and he's like hey just
just say it happened under Trump and
they were like oh that's a good one okay
and then they call up their their
favorite journalists and say hey here's
the story and they go you got it and
they run it
I wonder if the journalists call them
they're like we'll just say it happened
to their Trump and they're like thanks
they called the journalist and say I got
a tip for you I mean so their Anonymous
official says this but we know not long
ago 51 actual officials said that the
Russia thing was true 51 of them
remember that all 51 of these big dogs
saying oh no no this this whole Russia
it's not a hoax it's not a hoax of
course we find out it absolutely was a
hoax but now it's an anonymous official
nobody wants to put their name on it so
I mean what does that even mean they
think we're stupid and unfortunately
well fortunately for us we're not I
think there's a lot of Americans that
want to go what's the big deal it's a
stupid balloon well those are the people
you really can't help at this point but
for the rest of us who are thinking
people and know what's really going on
in the world and we know what the
dangers are that's a big big deal to see
something like that you know you're
talking about a communist Chinese enemy
of the United States floating a
militarized vehicle all the way across
the mainland it came 50 miles North in
Nashville wow right now it was it was
too far out it was just 50 miles out of
Nashville
but I mean for that to be going on in
it almost seems like uh you know like I
said earlier there are people in this
country that want to see America go down
they want to see it happen the second
you get the second anybody listen to
this you're looking at the situation
going I can't believe people are that
stupid I can't believe these people are
that inept they're not stupid and
they're not inept at all it's all
calculated it's all part of it again you
can't have one world money one world
medicine one world militaries as long as
America is standing up on both feet
America has to be reaching up for hand
what's the only way any person can reach
up to something they have to be lower
than what it is they're reaching up to
well America is not lower than anybody
right now you got to put America down on
a knee what's a good way to do that oh I
don't know let some balloons float
across the country and turn the lights
out one time just an idea in uh in 2012
I went to the largest hacker convention
Defcon and black hat and happened about
the same time August in Las Vegas and at
the black so Defcon is
well I got some Choice words for the
people at Defcon these days I won't go
there ever again but uh it used to be
legit hacker Community stuff now it's
just like overrun with woke fear there's
also another conference called hackers
on planet Earth they did someone of a
better job but the woke people have
really overrun the Hager community and
they're like they're not even really
hackers but anyway I digress I was there
in 2012. and black cat is more corporate
uh cyber security and things like that
and a couple of guys were doing a
demonstration on how a single this is
2012 mind you a single commercial drone
that cost 200 bucks
could have a transmitter placed on it
that if flown within 40 miles of any
kind of plant with with receiver with
some kind of receiver on it it could
send a signal and destroy it
just that these other guys that did a
demo of how to blow up a fluid
processing plant this could be crude it
could be petrochemical it could be water
and basically what they said was with us
with a few lines of code injected into
their systems because they're like
insecure systems from the 70s you could
make the machine direct the fluid in the
same direction causing a massive
pressure pressure build up and then a
pipe burst which would disable a water
plant or blow up a petrochemical plant
and they did a demonstration where they
were like here's how it's they're called
industrial Control Systems they're like
here's how it works the machine says the
fluid shall go in this direction when
one tank needs to be changed or whatever
the fluid might go in the other
direction this is a common you know
mechanism in a lot of these plants if
both are turned on at the same time via
a hack the pressure in the center will
build up and the pipe will burst and
then what they did was they had a
pressure release valve so when they show
the flow of fluid going back and forth
they then press the button which hacks
it and then they hold out a mug and the
water sprays out and they catch it
saying that would have been an exploded
pipe but we had a pressure release valve
so it just sprays water on us
so you got to think about what a balloon
could really do and what our
understanding of it is we we don't even
know the capabilities of the military
they're not going to tell us they're
going to keep it a secret so there could
be good reason why they didn't shoot
this thing down and Fair Point it may
have been knee-jerky of us to be like it
should be shot down immediately I mean
jackpotobic said so fair point though
maybe he's also right in that whatever
they may have on it it may be better off
dropping in Montana or Alaska like you
mentioned than flying outside of
Nashville but I wonder if that's based
on our surface level knowledge and
understanding of what could be on the
balloon for all we know there was a
explosive on it when they say say
explosive what if it was okay let's go
let's go a little bit far-fetched do you
guys you guys know about the the concept
of antimatter bombs you probably do
right if when you take a particle an
anti-particle and you put them together
it creates intense explosive heat
theoretically explosive if they were
able to contain small quantities of
matter and anti-matter you could make a
very very small bomb with the force of
like megatons relatively small I don't
know the actual size I'm not a physicist
so theoretically if you could contain it
properly this is next level technology
weapons technology they could have been
thinking it's not an explosive like TNT
it's an explosive like a Megaton
radioactive bomb it says that one half
gram of anti-matter reacting with one
half gram of ordinary matter would
result in 21.5 kilotons equivalent of
the atomic bomb over Nagasaki the drop
and that's a gram yeah one gram of each
yeah so one gram of of material one gram
wow let's think about so so one one
thousandth of a kilogram so we're
talking about I mean
ridiculously gram people know what a
gram is 140 140 50th of a pound
microscopic now imagine if they had an
actual pound of this stuff I I don't
know if they do producing antimatter is
extremely difficult to do and that's be
contained I think in a magnetic ring but
hey look
do we think that technology from the 70s
is the epitome of weapons Tech these
days like they built icbms and we're
like all right we got these nukes that's
it we're done you know that Russia's
rolling out the Satan II missile the
tsunami bomb or whatever as well is that
it or do they actually like are they
going to publicly announce Russia's like
here's our doomsday weapon here's how it
works here's what it does I was just
listening to someone quoting Yuri
bessman off the Russian I don't know if
he's a philosopher or military
strategist exactly but he's noted as
like turning away from the Communist
party and I think kind of revealing
their plans to the Americans
xkgb he said that it used to be that it
was easier to control a million people
than kill them but today it's easier to
kill a million people than control them
very that rings in my head that that
thought that it's
you know it's hard to know the darkest
among us would have that in mind you
know part of what I think about all this
stuff is maybe maybe nuclear technology
really was the the the Pinnacle the
epitome you know uh they're they're long
periods of human history where
technological development stagnets
stagnates I look at the culture of
America and how it's kind of been
stagnant I'm like well you know maybe we
had this big boom with with with
discovery of petroleum and this massive
energy output and now we're we're easing
back into the stagnation where for
hundreds of years culture remained
relatively the same you lived the same
life your grandparents did and that
changed in the early 1900s with the
Industrial Revolution but maybe we're
going back to that and there's going to
be a long period of stagnation where I
mean you look at Warfare they used
muskets for hundreds of years
hundreds and for us in like the span of
100 years we've made some crazy weapons
we got lasers we got rail guns we got
active denial systems we kind of went
nuts maybe we now level out and
everything kind of plateaus and maybe
maybe nukes are it you know and there's
not a great technology to fear
explosions don't really scale up like if
you want to hit a Target if the
explosion's so big it's gonna go beyond
the target scale the target so more
explosion isn't necessarily better
explosion so I think that nuclear has
not really capped out like you're saying
a gram of energy could could do nuclear
bomb I'm concerned about like vibration
weapons and things that can like make
Things Fall Apart at the atomic scale
and stuff that we've never heard of or
conceived of well I think that would
require breaking apart like fundamental
forces right if you're gonna break
something apart at the atomic scale
you're talking about breaking apart or
the molecular scale is a little bit
better at least ripping atoms apart like
ionization and stuff oxidization can
rapid oxidization
an EMP kills more people ultimately than
any nuke that's a good you were saying
if it was an EMP we lose instantly like
they hit the right place every single
military
look uh look at that situation has said
if it was Nationwide or close Nationwide
it they estimate after a year 10 are
still alive and the problem with uh with
all of our big electrical
substations that around the U.S they're
all totally different because they're
built to handle that that amount of
power that kind of distribution they're
all very specific and unique the way
they're built and most of them are built
overseas of course and it's a 12 to 18
month wait to get one built and sent
over here
you know where they're built Germany
China is now building them of course
John is building uh our nuclear our
electrical substations uh it was it was
Germany China it was another country but
it's not here we're not building them
here I don't know what just like we
don't make antibiotics here you said
that China the Chinese government's been
building American electricals they are
now taking contracts to build them yeah
yeah but but my point is to your point
is about the this giant explosion is not
necessarily the way to go yeah I totally
agree I mean if you really wanted to
take a country over you don't want to
destroy the whole place you just want to
it you know knocking out
knocking out your lights Americans
wouldn't know what to do dude and all
power went out all the ammo that
American civilians have like if the
Chinese could get us to turn on each
other and waste all that ammo and that
would obviously it's pure Sun Tzu Art of
War you get your enemy to fight itself
kind of thing disorders
there's these viral videos coming out of
Ukraine that I don't know if they're
Real showing uh soldiers kidnapping
young men
kidnapping conscription call it whatever
you want to call it
um it could be it could be propaganda
videos you know there are these videos
that have gone viral where it shows a
crew filming a fake war scene and then
they're like aha we caught Ukraine
staging fake videos and I'm like yeah
but that could be Russia making a fake
staged video like I don't know who to
trust but I see videos you see soldiers
grabbing a guy and they claim it's
Ukrainian soldiers are going to the
homes of young men and taking them and
um I'm willing to believe it because of
course they do conscription is the
natural state of war and always has been
around the world forever if you lived
somewhere they would go to you and say
you fight for us or you're fighting
against us and if you're fighting
against us we're locking you up
so in the event the power goes out this
country is not equipped culturally
mentally and socially to deal with real
conflict and that is what you saw in
World War II the the U.S office of
censorship yeah that ain't gonna fly in
this country right now women doing
certain jobs Meats being sent overseas
to the Troops people being conscripted
you better believe if we go to war the
draft is coming back everybody and it's
and and we talk about well you've got to
be between 18 and 26 to be drafted yo
they will draft anybody and everybody if
the war is legitimate if the war is real
enough World War II they were grabbing
them into their 30s that's right yeah
yeah if you're a dude and and not only
that it's like you're fit you're going
to war baby because either that or we
cease to exist and it's easy for us
right now in this golden period or what
it may have been to just be alike we
can't have it we don't need it well yeah
the US is a it was a unipolar superpower
we owned and controlled everything but
that's going away right now we go back
to the way things used to be this
country is not equipped China drops an
EMP on this country and you are going to
have oh man part of me just really would
love to see the reaction from the woke
left and the Socialist young Millennials
in gen zeers when they're like but I
don't understand why I can't have food
and it's like because there isn't any
well you wouldn't see it Tim because
you're not gonna be able to turn on your
iPhone or your laptop to see what
they're saying well there's no
electricity but I gotta be honest I
think I I think we will all suffer
people in this room the people listening
though probably going to have
electricity not every single person mind
you but see
the people I hang out with they like
build Faraday cages and microwaves are
also Faraday cages and I know people who
have put microwaves in Faraday cages and
buried it with phones and laptops in it
so a lot of people on average are
probably going to be caught off guard by
this but you go out to the middle of
nowhere and people got gas generators so
an EMP hits the central Grid it's not
going to hit every little house in the
middle of nowhere that little house in a
little nowhere power goes out great
their generator kicks on and look I
wonder what just happened turn on the TV
they're seeing they're seeing limited
news reports because I mean if the EMP
hit every single City maybe they'd see
something but there's going to be some
Communications Technologies however the
cities will lose their their their Hub
status and then all of a sudden yeah
people are they going well this is gonna
be a funny thing people are going to be
looking for News New York gets knocked
out Chicago La gets knocked out all the
cities let's say let's say China's able
to knock out the Grid in the major
cities most of them there will still be
some news coming out from some because
they're not going to get every single
one let's be realistic but all of a
sudden you're going to see conservative
blogs are the only ones up and running
sharing information and that's all
you'll get because they're gonna you got
generators you got your own power you're
off the grid not to mention Preppers
you're gonna have some prepper guy and
he's gonna take over the airwaves and be
like I'm what you got for now until they
can kick this stuff back on I bet though
that whatever's running the government
would have so many backups upon backups
and they would just start churning out
propaganda in a situation like that
making your phone Buzz even though
you're like how do how's it ringing I
don't even have a connection but it's
like everything is okay stay in your
house the President says everything's
okay and you're like oh my God remember
the Hawaii missile strike thing that
went out yeah yeah that was crazy people
in Hawaii got to learn their phone
saying a missile was detected coming
from North Korea like shelter and place
or whatever it was an accident it wasn't
like it's all over and people were like
oh we're gonna get nuke this is a
terrifying conversation no no listen
that that phone test
when that message went out I don't think
it was an accident no I don't think it
was either I think they wanted to see
the reaction people would have how the
economy would be impacted they wanted
the data yeah well you might be right
actually I have done stuff like that in
the past with the Tuskegee experiment
where I mean they'll just use people as
guinea pigs or pawns is it still PC to
say call people guinea pigs these days
uh this is a conversation we should have
this is a terrifying racist okay good
um but you just coming after you
tomorrow this is a conversation that Joe
Biden should be having publicly with us
we need that's right that's why we're
bringing this up it's a stupid balloon
floating across the country is how a lot
of people see it so what it's a stupid
balloon they're not understanding what
that actually could be at some point
Trojan Horse right we they they see the
big gift horse come up they're like oh
this is a wooden Horse let's bring it on
in and then a bunch of troops come out
start killing everybody it's a balloon
who cares it's a surveillance balloon oh
it's I I had people actually saying like
well didn't China say that it was just
like a civilian thing and I'm like oh
come on like that's not even China right
let's not even play it again you said it
oh yeah you know they make all of our
stuff so they have to be reliable but as
a good civilian labor force is connected
with the CCP directly the way that it
interfaces so anything civilian in China
That's run by the CCP is basically run
by the CCP yeah I think my brother was
saying that he was like isn't everything
in China the CCP anyway and I'm like
yeah that's that's that's true actually
yeah it is there's no there's no
civilian so this is the thing you got to
watch out for actually it's not going to
be a fighter jet that flies over from
China shooting at us it's gonna be a
gigantic you know what uh don Jr tweeted
the the Trump baby Trump balloon it's
gonna be that it's going to be Barney
and people are going to be like look at
this there's a there's a balloon that
got blown off course and it's Barney and
then also it's gonna pop and it's gonna
spray down acid all over the thing that
gives me hope and it's still dark hope
but is that that CCP is like capitalist
they're extremely hyper capitalist
businessmen and they want a trade
relationship with the United States I
see no world in which they would attack
the United States or that the United
States would attack China makes no sense
there will be border infringements like
taking Taiwan us you know well the Iraq
thing wasn't really a border
infringement but we should you know if
if the United States were to Annex
Mexico for instance in the united then
it was the United States of of North
America or whatever we become or or
something like that but I see no reason
for us to go to conflict it would
annihilate every major city in China
would get annihilated with nuclear
weaponry every major city in the United
States it would be not good for anybody
anybody including Xi Jinping and his
buddies
yeah that's where they're taking over
Africa yep with money economically it's
all this economic stuff resources and
economics and then if they can get us to
buy their products with their money I
mean I think that's the ultimate thing
is like actively working in a lot of
ways to already control America right
like there are a number of Senators
who've introduced legislation trying to
stop basically entities of the CTP from
buying agricultural land in America this
is like one of the the big ways that
China doesn't have to go to war with us
they just have to move in through uh
channels we already present to them
right they buy as enough Farmland they
don't need to trade with lessons each
Traders themselves they just need to use
the resources that we have left open for
them to take I do want them to
understand what de facto control means
though and if you just because you have
a piece of paper over there that says
that you own that over there if you're
not there defending it you don't own it
someone's going to take it and control
it now they probably know that but good
luck I mean what are you going to do so
they they hope for good relations so
that we don't say you know what all this
crap all this paperwork's burned in a
fire at Star land get out you know don't
even make a move
um where they send citizens of China too
that they would try and like send like
well they would send mercenaries that
weren't Chinese that they were going to
defend it they would try and get
corporate militants and they'd be like
hey it's not Chinese shouldn't be
illegal to sell American soil to an
enemy of the United States yes I mean
are American farmers buying land in
China any foreign government it should
be illegal to sell American land well
here's another trick too you know you
want something crazy you let's say
you're Russian you want to be American
anyone in any part anyone from anywhere
can start a company in the United States
you do not need to be a U.S citizen
so what they'll do is they'll start a
company they'll invest in the company
then they'll try they'll get an H1B visa
to hire themselves move themselves to
the country and use that as a means of
getting Visa access
among other ways they can become
citizens the the the truth is however if
you are rich you can be a citizen
anywhere you want you literally can just
buy citizenship anywhere it's called
economic I think economic citizenship
when it comes to uh the people buying
Farmland I've heard this the Chinese are
buying American Farmland who is is it
the CCP directly or are there yes
private entities there's such thing as
private entities they all work for the
Chinese government I mean part of the
thing in China is every company
Works in support of the Chinese military
Chinese government so it's it's the
Visage of private companies doing it but
then it's just obvious that it's private
companies in China so you would think of
it as a private company but they are uh
tied to the Chinese government so
therefore they are in support of the CCP
you're sorry no I was gonna say that's
how it works They Don't Really infringe
a lot of um after a certain point of
income or a certain amount of money that
they're trading was generating as a
company then you have an attache of the
party that becomes part of your company
and helps you advise you on what to do
but underneath that all the smaller
business that goes on in the country
They Don't Really police it they don't
worry about it they just kind of say you
know whatever but after a certain amount
of money they're like hey we gotta we
gotta chat we have to have someone come
and watch out what you're doing is there
like a list of Chinese landowner
American landowners Chinese citizens
that own American land is there
something where you can put like it's
this company Joe Biden owns a place in
Delaware so let's start there
[Music]
[Laughter]
a good one oh good old job I mean
wouldn't it depend on the state too like
how publicly available the records are
you could probably trace it back but I'm
sure China's not trying to make it
obvious right like I don't know if you
remember a couple uh a couple months ago
there was this uh execution style murder
in at a pot farm in in Oklahoma and five
Chinese Nationals died there oh yeah and
it's owned by a Chinese company and the
man then fled to Miami I think he he got
extraded back to Oklahoma and he is also
a Chinese citizen like obviously and
like the local police are like this was
a farm and then it got bought and
just so you know to the public like we
don't think there's any reason to fear
we don't think it's someone who's going
to hurt you this appears to be an
inter-company issue I mean they are all
tied to China specifically the Chinese
government uh you can't operate a
business in America without the Chinese
government knowing it if you're Chinese
National yep do they like on the books
have control of the company
I mean it wins right it's
we know right
if uh every company in China has I think
at a certain level a CCP CCP liaison
office or whatever inside the company
correct yeah and it's very much the same
way the Nazis ran things so I was
reading this academic paper on the
Nationalist socialism of of the Nazis
and and why it was and wasn't you'll
hear the left say they weren't really
socialists they were using that in name
only well the way it worked was the
Communists came and pointed a gun at
your mouth in your mouth and said this
is this is what we're doing they made a
public announcement everyone must do
this for the good of the collective the
Nazis would be like no no no people
should run their own businesses but you
wouldn't work against our interests
right right you're you're making steel
for the War aren't you you're not a
sympathizer are you and oh no so almost
the exact same thing but coerced in a
slightly different way with China it's
basically that it's you don't you're not
against the the the people are you and
so people are working at their behest
and you see what happened to Jack ma the
uh Alibaba about a year ago a year and a
half ago he just disappeared for three
weeks or something and then came back in
his other company which was worth I
don't know the numbers exactly half a
billion was stripped in half the value
is like his net worth was like shuttered
shattered in half I mean this is one of
the complaints about Tick Tock right now
Tick Tock uh has at least pardon bite
dance that's a company
bite dance uh both companies have
members of the Chinese Communist party
as part of their board and then they're
a data collection company and under the
2017 National Intelligence act in China
if you collect data you are obligated to
share it with the Chinese government and
therefore with the CCP and so if Tick
Tock is collecting American data it
means a big controversy Tick Tock says
that they're not storing data in China
they're storing it out elsewhere and
American people are safe but by the
terms of service Tick Tock has access to
your phone's location and your browsing
history and all kinds of personal
personal data so if bite dance and Tick
Tock are not honoring this claim that
they're actually securing the data which
I don't know how they could if they're
under Chinese National Law obligating
them to turn over data then it's an
incredible vulnerability that is
basically a hole in every American's
pocket who has the app which is kind of
crazy yeah um Airbnb also was I think
Vivek ramaswamy who's awesome brought
that up and that I mean that's like
where you're staying where you're
sleeping what your phone number is how
much money you spent what your bank
account number is are they sharing bank
account numbers with the CCP sure
blizzard the company the gaming company
just left China a couple weeks ago do
you guys know anything about that I ca I
couldn't figure out if it was because
they didn't agree with the CCP or if it
was too expensive sometimes it's too
hard to operate in China like I think
LinkedIn finally shuttered in China last
year because it just it doesn't work and
and they would the Chinese government is
more supportive of apps that are
controlled and run by the Chinese
government and so even if they have like
a partnership because they're a
different kind a different company uh
that's not National Channel you have to
partner with a company in China to
operate there it just becomes too
difficult right there's too much
bureaucracy and they'd rather direct
everyone to their social media platform
and the thing is a lot of companies will
have like they'll just literally have
the police come in and say hey everyone
give us your smartphones you know give
us your laptops Etc they'll clone all
your stuff take all your your
information your um in the US we call
like your uh what sort of intellectual
property we'll just say hey we know this
stuff because reasons you know oh you've
been in China that'll happen yeah for
sure that's why a lot of businesses are
left and if you question it you're
questioning the Chinese Communist party
and you wouldn't be a kind of
revolutionary would you no you wouldn't
oh I see fortunately I don't have to
answer that isn't it pathetic though
what Americans are willing to give up in
exchange for some entertainment that it
is the convenience dude just in exchange
for tick tock oh it's entertaining uh
and and then you tell them you know
they're watching everything you're doing
every keystroke is monitored they know
like you said do they know your bank
account information probably don't know
but they might but yeah but the but the
videos are funny but everyone I know is
is on it like especially with young
people that's the pressure right you
don't want to know what we think
nowadays yeah oh it's yeah but it's a
fun app so whatever it's never gonna
it's never gonna affect me and there's I
think a state of mind that like if you
get famous then you're set for life
financially which is not necessarily
untrue if you do it right and you use
Fame properly people will support you if
you're good if you're cool but like
that's terrifying that people are like
are willing to sell out their security
for fame
and like it's almost like I think
because it's intangible right if I told
you if you open Tick Tock someone's
gonna come punch you in the face you'd
be like yeah I probably won't be Tick
Tock but the idea that someone would
steal your private data and that this
would be used to threaten National
Security like it just becomes sort of
two meta or a 16 year old who's like but
my friend posted this video it hasn't
happened yet there's been no overt Act
of War regarding human data collection
that we've known that we've seen yet I
think after that happens if there is
like a genetic like they make tailored
you know Gene weapons that people that
gave to 23 and me now they have all
their genetic code and they can kill a
certain amount of peoples because they
have their genetics then people be like
whoa whoa whoa whoa but then it's too
late and that's why you need people to
be proactive about like being careful
about the data that they give to the
world and Tick Tock is an easy way to
get people to say like oh it doesn't
matter also giving false data is is
better than giving no data in a lot of
instances because then you can throw
them off off the trail
would you let your kids on Tick Tock
they're probably absolutely not no
matter of fact my son just turned 13 and
he's been asking for an iPhone since he
was 11. my friends have iPhones I said
okay I said well what are you going to
do on the iPhone that you can't do on
your Apple watch because the Apple watch
is for him to text me if he's at a
baseball practice or something or your
iPad which you play games on or your
Chromebook which is a little computer
they get at school to do to do their
studies on I go what are you going to do
with an iPhone that that you can't do on
your Chromebook iPad or Apple watch he
looked at me and he went
probably nothing I guess I said okay
well when you're 13 we'll talk about it
well man that just drove him crazy but
when he turned 13 I made him sign a
contract with me on the phone there's
two pages and it was a lot but I said uh
I John Rich your father am loaning you
this iPhone because I purchased it so
it's mine I'm loaning it to you and here
are the rules and stipulations for you
to maintain the phone and so it goes in
and one of the things is you're not
allowed to download any social media
apps absolutely none if I find one
social media app a repossessed the phone
we I said I am mirroring your phone so I
put an app in his phone and an app and
my phone and his mother's phone or
anything that comes in and out of his
phone we see it wow and I said that's
for your own protection because of some
bad guy or you think it's not a bad guy
or what if somebody you don't know is
trying to get in touch with you I'm
gonna see it I'm gonna I'm gonna find it
and keep it from happening and so on and
so forth and he's been he's been tight
with it you know but I think
teaching your kids again your opponent
earlier a lot of kids don't have good
parents unfortunately but I try to be a
good parent I'm going I told my son
everything evil on the face of God's
Earth is on the other side of this phone
every bad guy in the world you know
people that I would shoot if they came
in our front door there's millions of
them on the other side of this phone and
they want to get you thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time